I mean it's when you uh I learned as a
as a kid you know when you dish it out
you got to be willing to take it and for
as many times as I've done it to people
you know I can't be upset when um
somebody else does it you know what I
mean I think that's also
um a sign of respect and acknowledgement
for you know knowing my history and
knowing what I do and uh you know I I
didn't mind it um was what it was I just
I've also known that you know when you
having your moment is it's important to
be careful and to to be humble when you
having your moments cuz you just never
know how to table was turn and when they
going to turn so um I respected it you
know I didn't think we shook hands after
the game and I I wasn't moved by it left
or right